if you would ask my friends were gonna
watch movies with me to tell you one
thing
sixty percent of the time I walk out of
the movie
I literally get up and walk out a movie
I don't know anyone that walks out of
movies more than I do because I don't
like to waste my time watching a movie
without a point to it and you can't keep
my attention to be watching the movie is
kinda like reading a book for two hours
give me a message move me to tap into my
emotions humor anger
laughter you know whatever I want I want
to feel the pain i want to feel it right
and so I think the part of the
entrepreneur that's got the creative
side were to bring always go and it's
got the imagination you're always
thinking thinking thinking things movies
helps a lot in tapping into that
imagination at least it does for me and
I know a lot of other people that I've
had many many movie nights with people
that I was measuring and building and
many many movie nights because we're
going to sit there and I remember one
time movie came out is in my top 10 list
no but I think it's my top 100 this i am
legend came out if you remember i am
legend a lot of people in all it's a
terrible movie
terrible movie and I said what do you
mean it's a terrible movie I think the
same 10 people that's a terrible we went
to the movies to get us and I want you
to watch you seven different points
this means this that means this this
mean i never thought about it as i said
i am a legend is the life of an
entrepreneur work if you look at it from
the eyes of an object a life of not only
that makes so much sense
so it's also known what point you're
trying to get from the books that today
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
cover with you top 10 movies for me as
an entrepreneur and why you ought to
watch it and I'm going to make my points
for each one of them on why you want to
watch it so number 10 for me as a social
network many of you have probably why
social networks i may put it a little
bit higher than -
social network or tail tells a very very
good story of Mark Zuckerberg who builds
facebook and when you're building
facebook what things they went through
you know a college kid 18 years old
if you put your minds together what
you're capable of building but it also
talks about the darker side ideas being
stolen
somebody takes it away from you
it was somebody else's how do you
protect the idea can you ever protect
your ideas someone can take it and make
it better than you
what do you do with that do you need
NDA's do you need NCS then when they
interviewed Zuckerberg and they said hey
what did you think about the movie you
know what is best comeback was said you
know the movie shoulders party a lot
more than we work as i remember party
that much
I remember working a lot I remember
working a lot another thing about the
movie of a social network that's very
important Zuckerberg was not the
visionary October was a technician
he was the product guy but he was a
visionary then showed up our sean parker
sean parker is the guy that started
Napster Sean Parker comes and he says
this is not a million-dollar opportunity
this is a billion-dollar opportunity and
Mark didn't see that
and then all of a sense to get this
could be a billion opportunity then both
Facebook becomes what it is today being
worth 200 200 300 billion dollar conform
billion dollar company and the stock
keeps going up the broad Sheryl Sandberg
who figured out a way how to make money
for the company on you know fan pages
and advertisement all this other stuff
so I think this story there's a lot to
be learned from the story when you watch
it as an entrepreneur also gives you a
lot of inspiration know you're not the
only one that's going to craziness
number nine is not a movie it's a show
it's a series i've never ever in my life
I've never I've never in my life ever
watched any show from the beginning to
the end never but I had a friend of my
car loss from Ohio is a Cleveland guy
who are him and my dad simultaneously
within a minute or two they sent me a
text pad you gotta watch house of cards
I'm like listen I'm not gonna watch
shows just watch house of cards i'm not
gonna watch house of cards what are you
talking about
just watch house of cards i said okay
i'll get to it every time
house of cards that kept coming up with
everybody house of cards house across
now watch out watch shows I don't do any
of that stuff so it's Saturday tomorrow
at one o'clock at Sunday
on a Saturday the next day i'm supposed
to go to Italy
I got a flight to Tuscany I'm taking 40
50 of our friends we're gonna go to
Tuscany and God we rendered a 20,000
square-foot village gonna have a great
time together
okay great so on the way to the village
before going to the middle of that night
i said i watch one of so might that
contact just watch one episode ten
o'clock and i watch one episode
he watches to with me now at eleven
o'clock he goes home
i watch all 13 episodes that night and
go to sleep and I went on the flight to
Italy myself slept the entire way there
and I think it's 12 or 13 episode
somebody's at 13 episodes are 13 of the
first season
it teaches you the darker side of
politics on what happens in politics but
there's a part of it that also has to do
with business because in business
there's a lot of negotiations there's a
lot of things that happens behind closed
doors that you know on the front end
everything looks great oh my gosh
so good we're doing so well behind
closed doors
I am I am fights all this crazy stuff
that happens
power plays that people try to pin you
in a corner and they try to do this and
all this other stuff I think there's a
lot good to be alone there's a lot of
darker things in india in the house of
cards said that doesn't necessarily
happen that dark and business it doesn't
get bigger but not necessarily as you're
trying to get two million bucks or two
million bucks but I think there's a lot
to be learned from house of cards when
you watch it so that's number nine
number eight
Goodfellas let me tell you why I put
number 8 as good fellows with Ray Liotta
and the nero and Pesci one of the things
about Goodfellas is knowing that you
know sometimes someone could turn on you
and don't let you change your values and
principles on what you believe in
stick to your values and principles but
no and study people's trends on how
people's trends are will typically trust
trends
a lot of people coming from the papal
your son have changed i want to do this
on the most loyal person i'm gonna be
with
I trust trends more than I do words is
what I do
so if you've got a friend or you got a
partner you got somebody that's close
with you that there's trends of too many
things that just seems like a little bit
of shyster little bit of a little bit of
that this guy could turn on me
you need a little bit of paranoia with
that there are certain people like seven
different bad things happen every time
to scroll or disguise my back
these are solid trends I don't really
worry about anything happening there but
this guy's got way too many trends
sometimes you need a little bit of
paranoia with certain people not
everybody but certain people you need to
trust your gut and your intuition as
you're building business
that's what Goodfellas tells me number
seven is pursuit of happiness pursuit of
happiness is with will smith and his son
right and a lot of pursuit of happiness
because pursuit of happiness a great
story are Brax to riches you know you
can go up there and wrecks to riches and
the one thing I love most
obviously he worked at morgan standing
with her Chris Gardner I actually can we
put a picture of Chris Gardner night at
one event
uh you know gentleman asked me to host
it i think i hosted the event and I
brought up Chris Gardner and it was
great introducing them and getting a
chance to speak to him and he ran a
story because he's a Morgan standing
with God the things i love about grip
the movie pursuit of happiness 'as a
single father who made it happen with no
excuses but most importantly is the
efficiency of his time when he was
making cold calls i did call calling for
a long time with my business and it was
knowing that the most important skill
set you gotta run as an entrepreneur is
selling and hustling
if you're not selling and hustling from
five thirty in the morning till ten
o'clock 11 o'clock at night
did you gonna you're not it's you just
decreasing your chance of making it
there's a certain level of a hustle that
the entrepreneurs got to have and he
took it to the highest level and you
know the story of what happens with him
and
business all that other stuff and now
they do a movie about some pretty
phenomenal story so i reckon pursuit of
happiness that touches on a lot of
different things number six is a movie
i'll probably watch the most times in my
life because when I was in the Army we
probably watch this movie two hundred
times and most people haven't seen this
movie and some people will say is Tom
Cruise worst movie of all time and it's
called cocktails cocktails to me was
phenomenal i mean i've seen cocktails
I don't know how many times we've come
back from boot camp will not boot can we
come back from work from the motor pool
we hit the gym Estep at fort campbell
kentucky hundreds airborne division
would come back
put on a movie what you want to watch
cocktails or roadhouse but typically
cocktails one and we watch cocktails and
the great thing about cocktails is
here's a guy was a bartender was a
dreamer
ok was a dreamer and events he's always
reading books always reading books
always and this other guy who plays so
well my gosh she's such a great actor
who is constant look at him there's this
one scene where he spied him in jamaica
and the other guy the bartender's
partner who takes a girl away from him
is at the bar and he's not with a rich
girl which is what both that I wanted to
do and Tom Cruise the character date a
girl who he falls in love with but
decides to leave her for another rich
because you wanted to marry into a rich
girl but he didn't realize that that
girl is richer than any of these other
girls and it's a very very good story of
a guy that went from nothing and at the
end he starts his bar i think the
cocktails and dreams or something like
that and just a lot of great lines it's
a very emotional movie on the fact that
it becoming an entrepreneur is not about
being a billionaire
son of a celebrity status it's not about
you know having the cars i mean i bought
a Ferrari because i truly love
Enzo's mind I'm a visionary product
today my wife and I were seen having
lunch at ph and we're debating over kid
their kids name our daughters do today
today baby is due today
she's 40 weeks today my wife any point I
can get a text or call and I gotta run
off and go to the hospital with her and
we're seeing that we're going through
names for babies and she's telling me
how you know this name I want to stay
because at this name
you know that person was this
and that presented this and i'm saying i
want this one because this person do
this on a story behind it
I mean I respect and so for what he
designed i want to Italy to his
headquarters in a three-time ferrari
world champion drop me in the ferrari
458 italia and I 167 miles an hour and
rain and a two-lane highway and
maranello and i said i want this thing
but entrepreneurship is not about
wanting that thing
it's not just about the Ferrari or fifty
thousand dollar watch are living in a
multi-million dollar has 10,000 that's
fine but the story of an entrepreneur is
a guy that just says man i want to build
my business
I want control I want happiness I want
to make money i want to build my own
identity
I want to free this what I want to do
and they do it and that's the story of
cocktails
it's a very you don't have to be a
billionaire to be identified as an
entrepreneur you could simply run a bar
that everybody in the community comes to
friday saturday
there's the same people that come
because you do such a great job and you
make one twenty year but it's a
restaurant the community knows about
that's what cocktails about love that
movie number 5 number 5 is a casino
number five is casino and one of the
things about casino is is important when
you watch the casino is knowing you know
which bridges to burn and which bridges
not to burn casino is also about knowing
that someone who was once your enemy
could now end up being your biggest ally
and somebody who was your biggest friend
can now be end up becoming your biggest
enemy
it also teaches you how to cross you not
to cross it teaches you to know that if
you keep consistency and build a credit
in the streets or in business of
delivering and being a leader you will
generally be fine if you're the guy that
delivers on your promises and if you
don't arm eventually no one trusts you
and you end up being alone hence you
know how the movie ends
this is also Pesci movie and it's also
De Niro movie see how the movie ends and
the Nero was a guy that was probably the
most stand-up guy and he kept building
and somebody else wanted it faster
wanted to power all this other stuff
it also talks about
choosing the right spouse choosing the
right partner
you need somebody new corner and being a
little bit more diligent about that than
just a fun part
sharon stone I think there's a lot of
great messages and casino that anybody
can pick up as an entrepreneur number
for let me know whenever force
number four is a movie that was a friend
of my Steve event and told me to watch
many many years ago and i have heard
about the movie but I never watch it's
called The Count of Monte Cristo and
some of you may say so my gosh one of my
favorite movies count of Montecristo is
a great movie because you know it's a
it's a story of the reason why this
connects with me a lot and it resonates
with me a lot because I'm the guy that
went from being a couple of my life was
a complete 180
no one believes my friends can't connect
with me today because they don't
understand what the hell happened to
Patrick David it's very difficult and I
don't try to put them in their face or
say anything to them about my success I
don't ever bring up the top of money or
any of this stuff that I mean when we
talk we just got how you doing what's
happening with family because i made a
complete 180
i went from the guy that parents and
stay away from 1.8 all this other stuff
trouble
chasing squirrels chasing girls it's all
I wanted to do that was my priority from
morning till night I mean I club that
went to bars I ipod good
it was so important to me till 21 22 and
then all of a sudden one event that has
a heart attack
I read a book and I just completely
flipped
I hit rock bottom girl left me crush my
heart
nothing in the bank I'm alone in a
corner in a while cry like a little baby
at 21 22
I've been hustling I've been doing
everything I lost my identity and I said
I cannot stand this identity
I hate this identity I want to prove a
point to myself that I have more to do
my life because I don't know why
something in my belly tells me I'm
destined to do some special my life this
was 21 22
I felt like this since I was a kid but
this was the first time that there was a
purpose behind it and Count of Monte
Crisco christos about a person
re-creating themselves is about how you
recreate yourself into person that
nobody else recognizes and all of us and
you become the guy that everybody
is listen to because your voice has
become so big and people choose to want
to follow your voice not force as a
dictator choose to want to follow your
voice because of what you're doing to
people and how to completely change
yourself
that's what the movie is all about great
movie
number four spot number three we get
closer number one number three number
three is a movie
BYE MOM men who a lot of this guy's
acting
there's a Washington to me as incredible
as well as russell crowe to my favorite
guys in the same movie
you probably already know what movie
this is American Gangster is purely and
entrepreneurs movie some of you guys may
say about every single move your
recommended as a gangster movie or
somebody getting killed
but I tell you why American Gangster
number three American Gangster is a
story of distribution
American Gangster is a story of
mentorship you remember the way the
movie starts
you know a frank lucas his mentor with
somebody was shadowing and he wasn't
trying to overpower his mentor
one day his mentor at a furniture store
dies and has a heart attack and the
legacy gets passed down to Frank Lucas
and Frank made it even bigger
right now yes it was blue magic yes
we're talking drugs yes it was something
terrible but take the concept of
distribution
here's a mentor somebody you watched
every move watch everything he's doing
every single think he's saying every
single habit giving away turkey doing
this one are you watching every single
thing you're watching your learning
you're seeing a fight that the guy
that's a fighter streets respect he's
got street cred people respect to Scott
I'm warning from this cat home now it's
my turn now what do you do with that
luck is you're going to be arrogant
cocky thinking it's all about yourself
and let that get your head
are you really gonna advance the slides
in he gets to work and he becomes a
leader
the brothers following the cousins
everybody comes and starts working for
him yes high standards
one time he slips with a standard the
reason why I ended up costing his entire
business
where's to flash it with cody never wear
flashy cuz you always said only the most
loudest person in a room so he goes to
wear this flashy cause it's girls
started buying into the nice stuff
he made a mistake he can get his girl to
realize it's not about all the nice
stuff only we got a state we got to stay
strong got in bone
you got caught and the next thing you
know
the rest is history what takes place and
russell crowe comes into the questioning
and etc etc you know how this whole
thing is nobody expected him to be the
main guy everybody pointed to Armando
Santo asante who was the main put
everybody thought that was him but it
wasn't it was him a african-american man
running the entire shop is what made it
confused because you have to change
there's a scene at the end where they
change it up
she's the main guy is the American
Gangster at one point you have 275
million dollars of cash sitting around
not checking account cash sitting around
talking are 75 million you can put money
in banks anymore right
so he took it to a whole different level
phenomenal movie i put that number three
spot if you haven't seen it it's a great
movie to watch this is what number to
this is the all-time story
I think every entrepreneur has a certain
feeling of an underdog on us if you come
from a lineage or your family's been
into business and entrepreneurship and
they've done very well most
entrepreneurs typically connect with the
underdog story right
no one believes you could do it no one
believes you have what it takes no one
believes you have your smart enough no
one believes you have a working you see
division you buying - you working are no
one sees how are you working to getting
rejected rejected cheque knocked around
knocking on losing losing losing losing
fail fail been a boom you got a victory
and you know it took me ten thousand
hours to and you know 10 years to be an
overnight success that whole story you
hear about well that's what ends up
happening
and number two story is rocky number to
a movie to me is rocky
preferably for me is rocky for but some
like one two three
I mean I like 4i think five was also
good with Tommy Morrison six was the
sense this most recent was kinda weird
with Creed but you know you watch rocky
for it's a different story than you
watch rocky one
rocky one shows when you coming up and
you're hungry and you're going to the
pie you want to find a girl as well you
find a gentle friend
you gonna fight that no one's expecting
you do anything to draw an Iraqi to
comes and a 3 you going
facing someone like mr. T you know mr. t
coming in a clubber lang and all this
other stuff he's doing and you know he
calls your wife out and you you I'm a
better man a drink if you just fire
right in a rocky for comes if you made
it
and now you have so much money so much
car so much and then you're afraid of
losing it
you're afraid of losing it's no longer
about the game of boxing it's no longer
about the fight is no longer about just
what you love to be completely forgot
about the fact that you don't you love
the game
now it's all about the money you forgot
about the fact that everything you did
was the you know the the the South Park
coming no one's expecting he's a fighter
you can knock them out he's got a strong
job and in age and I'm afraid what you
afraid of I'm afraid I'm afraid but i
can't be afraid you know everyone's
afraid not be
I'm afraid and then that whole scene by
the water by that you know by the beach
look at this and he takes training
seriously the rival kills his friend
Apollo Creed he comes here to see where
his up the staircase and his wife's all
the way at the top and she's looking
down and you know someone you know and
understand anything is like you can you
want to die and he looks at us like my
life doesn't believe in me and he leaves
it gets in a car i think the Black Lotus
I think it's a black lotus and then home
he's driving and there's the scenes of
it's just like free membrane his friend
Paolo how we first came up and met these
are moments that happened to me and it
happens on how many late-night drives
have I had or have you had with you just
like over you doing this thing for from
the beginning why and then you're
thinking we had nothing we had nothing
going on and all of a sudden
why the hell are you taking it for
granted cherish what you build bring
that hunger factor back now what
happened
dig deep what is the next thing you're
gonna fight for that's Rocky for you
Rocky is any anytime bone some happens
right
number one I don't think there's a movie
that's going to teach you more about
leadership
entrepreneurship running the shop
running a business deal with conflicts
dealing with enemies dealing with
competitors than Godfather
I just don't think there's any of it
more than that and there's a lot of
stories and you know one is different
and two and three and everybody says one
is the best or something like - I don't
think too many people say three is the
best but it's typically what is
typically I would say first one right
and and you you see what happens who
comes into power and he didn't wanted he
fought it so much I don't want to be
this I don't want to live this life I
don't want to be this and pull some
happens to his dad and he takes it over
and he becomes three becomes any becomes
better than his dad and his respect and
his brothers didn't seem as that and add
the fat battle with the brothers and you
know the other scene with Andy Garcia
coming up and and he becomes three
becomes and I'm just a big fan of andy
garcia
it's just a very good movie Godfather is
a very good movie you learn a lot of
different lessons and godfathers
you know it's a very very good movie for
any entrepreneur to watch so i put that
at the top of my list and it's very hard
to beat that movie . they're just a lot
of lessons in a movie
so look these are my 10 I don't know
what your 10 / these are my 10 a matter
of fact I have a top 100 list have a top
100 list on my website that goes through
every book and every movie that is my
top 100 list and it explains why i think
is my top 100 list and that is on my
website Patrick david.com phone
go to that website see what the top 100
are and comment on the bottom
if you have not my first there's a movie
you've seen that I haven't seen comment
on the bottom i'd love to see it myself
you can even come on the bottom here on
what you got out of this one here
and by the way Mario need my pillow man
need my pillow my pillow my pillow
I'm gonna keep reminding you because we
need your help what we want to get this
channel we believe this is the number
one channel for entrepreneurs on youtube
so many of you who are the most
incredible fans loyal fans who comment i
try to get back to you guys every single
time you keep commenting and sharing
this with everybody
we appreciate it we love it as of right
now I think we're at 39 or 40 thousand
subscribers on this channel all goal is
to get 200,000 subs by august 31st we're
watching something very very major on
august 3rd week of august which will
announce to you a very very big very
very very very
big that will be announced to everybody
people keep telling me that I want to
learn more about entrepreneurship how
can i mentor me how can we do this
finally our team set palace with
something together so we agreed to it
and you'll find out what it is in the
next few weeks when we announced it will
be sure to subscribe to this channel if
you haven't done so and invite your
friends your peers also to get subscribe
subscribe to this channel goal against
to get 200,000 by august 31st with that
being said if you got any questions any
thoughts any comments comment on the
bottom
thanks for watching take care